what's up guys Jerry here I'm cruising
around and I figured I'd come in and
talk to you about a new movie cuz
there's been a lot of those lately at
summer 2015 there's a lot going on so uh
let's get right to it it's been a long
time man it's been a long ass time all
the Sun it's been a long time since
we've been to the wonderful world of
Jurassic Park you know we went we saw
the original park open then we saw the
aftermath of that we saw the toll those
dinos took on the Southern California
area and then later on we saw the
remnants of the other Island and Ned
Flanders and his adventures there and
now we're back we're back with the new
trip that's right Jurassic not park but
world and how's the movie let's talk
about this now now I gotta split this
review up into like two ideas because
I'm gonna tell you first and foremost I
had a really fun time watching this
movie I really enjoyed just myself in
the theater okay we went we saw it on
imax 3d on the 3ds okay but you know
seeing it big was really cool and a lot
of fun um and so I think there's a lot
this movie does get right it does get
everything right but it does get it
right and if you're there for dinosaurs
and you know a rollicking action
adventure that stuff I think it is
pretty good that stuff is a lot of fun
you know I kind of was swept up in that
wondering you know the dinosaurs are
cool the whole thing with him being able
to train and work with the Raptors was a
lot less cheesy in the movie than I
thought it was gonna be from trailers I
really liked the attention i paid to
animal behavior how Chris Pratt's like
training all the Raptors with a clicker
and treats and stuff like that whether
that the science is on it at least
seemed like some nice attention to
detail and I really like the amount of
effort they put into the park itself to
introducing Jurassic world as an
operational theme park and really
communicating just the awe of that thing
you know it's like I spent the first
half hour this movie
man I would love to go there like this
looks so cool I can see why somebody
thought this might have been a good idea
because Jurassic Park you know you don't
need to have seen the first movie to
sort of go this is probably a bad idea
is probably not gonna work out the way
you wanted it to and I feel like this
sort of the message of all these movies
and it never does but you know the first
part of this movie you know getting to
see the park and getting to spend time
there and all the different world
building in details I thought that stuff
was a lot of fun and it had sort of that
Spielberg e vibe um so props to them on
that and when you know [ __ ] hits the fan
so to speak I thought that stuff was a
lot of fun too um you know the cast is
all really charismatic I enjoyed Chris
Pratt I thought he brought a lot to the
role I liked him a lot more than I
thought I would based on that clip that
they kept showing us I like the kids I
liked bryce dallas howard i really liked
having Jake Johnson and Lauren lapkus
there to add some humor into things and
I really liked their contributions to
just the world and the story and I was
really happy every time they were on
screen especially Jake Johnson and Jake
Johnson gets some of the best dialogue
in the whole movie I mean everybody's
nowadays seems to want to throw in a
sort of phil lord chris miller esque a
self-consciousness moment or a joke of
some kind in this movie does that too
and I I thought Jake Johnson just really
did a good job with that and they're
even joking about you know name brand
stuff in terms of the dinosaurs and just
he's got a lot of really funny lines and
stuff like that and he's one of the
supporting characters I really enjoyed
Irfan Khan Oh Marcy like all the
supporting cast I really like the cast
they assembled Vincent D'Onofrio is good
too he's a bit of a 90s villain to me
he's sort of that guy with the big
military agenda who's you know all about
you know firepower and that sort of
thing but he doesn't find enough job
with that and you know the stuff if
we're talking a real critical review
like I said I had fun watching this
movie I really enjoyed my time there and
I would like to see it again it is a lot
of fun but as long as we're talking in
review terms you know there are some
definite flaws with this movie first and
foremost just some of the writing and
the characters you know there are some
really cool things there are some things
I like some
ideas they touched upon I like what they
did with the owner of the park being you
know this kind of new agey sort of
enlightened guy who's really into you
know the guest experience and and you
know respecting the majesty of these
animals and stuff like that and I like
the script over time starts to kind of
push the boundaries of that and reveal
that he is not completely in control he
doesn't know where everything is going
and he is [ __ ] up to in this situation
but um what I think really sort of
starts to take away from the movie for
me is um I really like Bryce Dallas
Howard I like her performance but the
writing of that character sort of drove
me nuts after a while because it's it's
like you can draw you know sort of very
by the numbers you know very organized
very sort of anal retentive character in
a way that's realistic and the problem
is this movie kind of draws her to be so
anal retentive and so inflexible to
anything that's outside you know the
book it's like they really drive home
just how rigid and structured she is you
know just how much she represents order
because there's always the theme of
ordering chaos in a Jurassic Park movie
and they draw her as such a slave to
order that it becomes ridiculous after a
while it's like given all the things she
has react to nobody would be that after
a while it's your chits dumb like you
know you would learn you know and it
takes her forever to learn in this movie
and when that character finally starts
to loosen up and finally starts to sort
of sink her teeth into the actual
situation at hand the writing of that
character gets better Bryce Dallas
Howard does a good job with it the whole
way through but they spend so much time
just punching you in the face with how
straight lace she is and how much she
doesn't view these creatures as
intelligent at all which just it just
doesn't seem like she would have gotten
to this point if she didn't understand a
little bit you know I just I kind of
hated that they made her so rigid for so
long because she just didn't seem like a
real person to me and I'm the Vincent
D'Onofrio character like I said kind of
comes across like a 90s villain in a way
where it's like a one-note guy you've
got this dream to use these animals you
know for combat purposes and stuff like
that and thing
again I didn't really like that story
line up until it started to pay off
later I could have done with that until
it starts to pay off and then when it
starts to pay off it gets a job done and
it's necessary i feel like the script
could have done a better job
incorporating it because it's like in
all the preliminary scenes with vincent
d'onofrio it's pretty clear like his
idea is pretty implausible if you're
that character watching the things that
are happening it doesn't seem realistic
as a plan so again that character kind
of comes off as dumb as well but you
know he's drawn as being a little bit of
a mean head so it's a little more in
line as opposed to the way they drop
bryce dallas howard the script does
leave certain things to be desired
especially in the way it draws certain
characters even though it's a bit lumpy
to me I generally liked the two brothers
I like the way they drew them for the
most part I liked what they gave them to
work on together they gave them some
life and you know ultimately it's a
summer blockbuster especially now um and
you don't go to these movies for you
know in the same amounts of well written
you know huh but there are some things
about this script that are well done I
thought and really clever and there are
other things about this script that I'm
like why why do we still need this like
you know why do we still have to have
you know cool bohemian guy and really
straight-laced woman and you know
selfishly for me I wish there had been a
better incorporation of animatronics and
puppets and stuff like that just because
you know the first Jurassic Park did it
it looked fantastic and the dinosaurs
here like these effects are top-notch
you know it's they paid top dollar for
these and it shows they're good um but
you know still there's that charm and
that realism that comes from a puppet
for an animatronic that I do miss they
used it here and there but not to the
degree they did in the first couple
films anyway the attention to detail is
really good there are some decisions
that are made that that feel really
realistic and there were some other
decisions that are made that feel very
unrealistic and you can feel the weight
of four writers you know not necessarily
as bad as you might in some other films
but you can feel that for writers had
their hands on this film because certain
things work a lot better than others
certain things are a lot better
developed than others you know just
based on that clip they showed us before
I kind of expected
to like Chris Pratt a little bit cuz
they pitted him and bryce dallas howard
against each other in that you know sort
of stereotypical way but I'm really kind
of tired of seeing and i'm surprised
we're still doing where it's like you
know oh we went on one date but you're
too straight-laced and I'm to bohemian
you know so I was fully prepared to hate
both of them kind of in different ways
but yeah it worked out better in the
movie than I thought it was going to
another two worked out great but I
thought both their performances saved it
from some of the pitfalls the writing
house I'm and the music's all good it's
really cool to hear the old theme again
the cinematography is good nothing like
overly flashy but it looks good they
shot their effects pretty well there
aren't like a lot of crazy shots but
they do a lot of good stuff with you
know wide angles just showing you the
vastness and and you know the sort of
detail of this park of this world I kind
of found myself missing the scope a
little bit because the first Jurassic
Park is really good at and like even
recently Godzilla was really good at
communicating scope and really making
you feel just how huge these creatures
aren't because this is a monster movie
you know and I going back you watch the
first Jurassic Park as a kid yo y'all
cool dinosaurs and you don't even
realize until you go back or at least I
didn't until I went back and saw it
again as an adult that that's not that's
a horror movie that's a monster movie
Jurassic Park is very scary and I'm I
kind of missed that in this one this
one's more action than it is monster I
could have done with a little more
suspense for my taste but that's just me
so I think if you're going back just to
have fun at jurassic park again you know
to see the spectacle of dinosaurs and
all that stuff I think you'll really
enjoy this for that reason it's a lot of
fun it's kind of an uneven film but
ultimately you know I had a lot of fun
that's what I went to this movie before
first and foremost I just want to have
fun I just wanted to be back at Jurassic
Park and that stuff is really good I had
a blast I want to go see it again just
just for the fun of it but in terms of a
film it's definitely got its flaws see a
drastic worlds the movie and what do you
guys think they're obviously gonna make
another one because they've
can so many box office records what do
you think we should see for the next
Jurassic Park movie let's talk about
that what would you like to see is there
a dinosaur you'd like to see come to
life because my favorite dinosaur made
it into this movie and I was really
happy so see a drastic world is the
movie I am Jerry until next time cheers